do you have
advice for young people today about how
to live life
or how to succeed in their career or
forget career just succeed in life
from an evolutionary computation
perspective yes
yes definitely explore
diversity exploration yeah and i mean
individuals take classes in music
history philosophy yeah you know math
engineering
uh see connections between them uh
travel you know learn a language i mean
all this diversity is fascinating and we
have it at our fingerprint
fingertips today it's possible you have
to make a bit of an effort because it's
not easy
but the rewards are wonderful um
yeah there's something interesting about
an objective function of new experiences
so try to figure out i mean uh
what what is the maximally new
experience i could have
today and that so that novelty
optimizing for novelty for some period
of time
might be a very interesting way to sort
of uh maximally expand
the the sets of experiences you had and
uh then ground from that perspective um
like what you what would be the most
fulfilling trajectory through life
of course the flip side of that is where
i come from again maybe russian i don't
know
but the the choice has a
uh choice is a has a detrimental effect
i think
from at least from my mind where
scarcity is
has an empowering effect so if i
sort of if i have very little of
something
and only one of that something i will
appreciate it deeply
until i came to texas recently
and i've been picking out on delicious
incredible meat i've been
fasting a lot so i need to do that again
but when you fast for a few days
that the first taste of a food is uh is
incredible
so the downside of exploration
is that uh
somehow maybe maybe you can correct me
but somehow you don't get to experience
deeply any one of the particular moments
but that could be a psychology thing
that could be just a very human peculiar
flaw yeah i didn't mean that you
superficially
explore i mean you can explore deeply
yeah so you don't have to
explore 100 things but maybe a few
topics where you can take a deep enough
time
a dive that you gain an
understanding you yourself have to
decide
at some point that this is deep enough
and i i
unders i i've obtained what i can from
this topic
uh and now it's time to move on and that
might take years
um people sometimes switch careers
and they may stay on some career for a
decade and
switch to another one you can do it
you're not pretty determined to stay
where you are
but you know in order to achieve um
something you know 10 000 hours makes
you need 10 000 hours to become an
expert on something
uh so you don't have to become an expert
but even develop an understanding and
gain the experience that you can use
later you probably have to spend
like i said it's not easy you got to
spend some effort on it um
now also at some point then when you
have this diversity and you have these
experiences exploration
you may want to um you may find
something that you can't stay away from
uh like for as it was computers it was
ai
it was you know that you i just have to
do it you know
and i you know and then we'll it will
take decades maybe and you are pursuing
it
because you figured out that this is
really exciting and you can bring in
your experiences
and there's nothing wrong with that
either but you asked what's the advice
for young people
that's the expiration part and then
beyond that
after that expiration you actually can
focus and and build a career
and you know even there you can switch
multiple times but
but i think the diversity exploration is
fundamental to having a
successful career as is concentration
and spending an effort where it matters
and and
but you're in better position to make
the choice when you have done your
homework
so exploration precedes commitment but
both are beautiful
you